[Music]
there are a few
incredible records in esports take the
2015 fnatic league of legends roster
that went undefeated
in their summer regular season or smash
4 player 0
who won 56 tournaments during that
game's first year
or ninjas and pajamas who dominated the
earliest days of cs go with an 87
map lan win streak but despite all the
victories
all the undefeated records there are
very few teams who've managed to pull
off the exact
opposite only one team was bad enough
unlucky enough
cosmically unloved enough to pull off
the longest winless streak in
esports history one team that totally
overhauled their roster and kicked their
best player in the middle of the season
ladies and gentlemen pros and scrubs of
all ages
let's talk about the longest losing
streak in esports history
let's talk about the shanghai dragons
the shanghai dragons just completed the
first season of the overwatch league
with an
unprecedented zero and 40 record yeah
you heard that right 0 and 40.
we checked and while plenty of teams
have come close to that record
no one's ever actually achieved it at
least not in a major esports league
there are plenty of league of legends
teams that have pulled off one win
seasons and a good number that went
winless particularly in the lpl and the
lms
but a league of legends split is
significantly shorter than an overwatch
season
notably there are a few cs go teams that
have gone an entire esl pro league
season without winning but they were all
disqualified before the season ended so
they don't really count but the shanghai
dragons now that
is a losing streak you have to get
really deep into some obscure
traditional sports to find
any team that's ever done worse across
the board no nfl
nba mlb or nhl team has done worse with
the longest losing streak
there coming from the philadelphia 76ers
who in 2015
lost 28 games straight across two
seasons
in the opening weeks of owl i've had my
suspicions growing
that for the shanghai dragons the league
might actually be
a punishment from the ancient greek
underworld the shanghai dragons seem
condemned to an eternal torture
where victory is perpetually just a
little bit out of reach
and here's the weird thing by the end of
the season the shanghai dragons roster
didn't look that bad on paper
they had a strong lineup of korean
players who were mostly overlooked
during the initial signing blitz ahead
of the first season
gegerie otto and fearless are all solid
players who helped the team improve
significantly when they were signed part
way through the first season
but the team's beginnings were a lot
worse the shanghai dragons were
the first team to get a name and a brand
when the overwatch league was rolling
those out
a few months later they revealed their
roster an all-chinese team made up of
players from various strong overwatch
rosters in china
but the wheels came off the wagon pretty
fast the team went
0-2 in the pre-season losing 4-0 to
seoul dynasty and
3-2 to the boston uprising and that may
be
it oh they get back there just in time
it was close the reds comes in for
roshan
so seoul having to back off a little bit
get back on the payload
that is gonna be it this time overtime
ticking off and seoul dynasty
will take this series 4-0 in maps
and they know what they're doing so he
sees dia he misses the flashbang missed
that bullet and collios gets the kill
that's at the end and now it's just
gonna be the end the graviton surge is
gonna bounce everybody around in the
corridor keep off the point they can
and boston uprising will take the win
over
shanghai dragons then in week one they
lost to the la gladiators and the san
francisco shock
and then they lost to the houston
outlaws and the florida mayhem
4-0 both times it was around this point
people realized that
shanghai had a problem and team manager
yang van
released a statement agreeing with that
it was also in that statement that he
revealed that the team had a
grueling training regimen practicing
from 10 30 a.m
each day until midnight but van also
said that the team was hungry for their
first victory this is where he gets out
of control
five king he will get the reds on undead
trying to keep him in the fight
tomic gets caught by mg still it is
gonna be florida mayhem
in the end picking up the third point
and a 4-0
victory over shanghai this is all on
diaz saving a blink to touch the point
keep overtime alive
but that's pretty much it with the whole
house using used to zone them out
the los angeles valiant win the match
four to zero
and it's worked out so well this far now
it's gonna be the transcendence you
can't break through that one he's still
getting buffeted around but it's all
bluff and blunder from the shanghai
dragons because they lack
the bark and the bites and that's it
after getting summarily dunked on for
the rest of stage one the dragons
returned for stage two with an
overhauled roster made up of those
aforementioned korean players
all of whom were considered some of the
best in their positions out of players
not yet in the overwatch league
he's coming back in with a tactical
fighter but he's gonna get pushed out of
position the transcendence from free
field he gets onto the payload but now
he's being used
knocked around the place no one for the
dragons can get back
close now there's no risk really going
aggressive here for the san francisco
shock and there's no margin of error
left for the shanghai dragon that's mg
down self-destruct the force away
it was an attempt something was being
done in the background
the shock making the four and zero four
with another big emp he's gonna use it
to help finish off refill and
everybody pretty much down widow can't
push the payload
by herself and that will be the la
gladiators getting a 4-0
here against the shanghai dragons so
that didn't work
after three more weeks of straight
losses head coach eu4 stepped down he
was replaced by
kong as interim coach and later by rui
as the new head coach
it mostly did nothing for the team they
went 016 in maps after u4
left then between stages two and three
the dragons dropped
undead their superstar dps player well
as much of a star as any 0-20 team can
really have on their roster
everything related to undead's departure
is hearsay but there were plenty of
allegations online that he cheated on
multiple partners either way even
without their star player it's not like
things could get much worse for shanghai
in fact things were starting to look a
little bit better they picked up their
best map record in stage 3 going 9-0 and
32
picking up dps player daemon to replace
undead
things were finally looking up for the
shanghai dragons but whatever light the
shanghai dragons saw at the end of their
tunnel was
quickly covered up by a cave-in the week
kicked off with a debut of a brand new
shanghai roster
but the acquisitions of gegerie and
company couldn't reverse their fortunes
as they still search for their elusive
first win
i'm the shanghai dragons my own 28
record
means i also have 28 straight losses
the record for most consecutive losses
by a professional sports team is 28
set by the philadelphia 76ers in 2014.
one more loss i own that awful record
should i win my next match against the
ny excel
or should i set the record you should
definitely win
no one wants to be remembered for losing
the most new york will be focused on the
playoffs
you can do this no no no
lose sets the record you'll be
remembered forever
shanghai actually ended the fourth and
final stage of the overwatch league with
the worst record they'd had since stage
two
that's right they actually managed to do
worse so
this is my third take on the shanghai
dragons and everything i have said
previously please just be nice this time
unacceptable trying to get to the
cafeteria dog so
we're running late
[Music]
it was not a good season they were only
40. they played badly they didn't win
oh and 40 not ideal there's nothing
there's not a lot of good things to say
with everything said and done the
shanghai dragons won 21 maps
tied to and lost 141.
the next worst team in the league the
florida mayhem won double the amount of
maps and while they only won
seven matches at least they made it
competitive sometimes
and again it's not like the shanghai
dragons were abject garbage
a lot of their players were strong
individual players
but they struggled when it came to
playing as a team just a lot of links
for his great
widow v widow play but so far d has got
the best room a couple of times
there he goes he balls and that's
unreasonable yeah that's awkward
he's looking right now and he's getting
on the point progress is being made yet
again nobody is on top of this
soon the soon special the soon special
background
he's not even going to fire a shot how
do they not know hush hush you guys are
going
to
so a chance here for shanghai to come in
and hold before the map can be completed
well the pulse bomb onto mg he's gonna
have to whoa what the
what okay yeah nobody's gonna get there
and no one from shanghai makes it onto
the payload so valiant finish with 42
seconds left
part of that might stem from the fact
that kong has told the korean players on
the team
not to communicate in korean during the
game instead he's having the players
speak in english or chinese
meaning a large chunk of the roster
arguably the most mechanically solid
part
was having trouble communicating with
the rest of the team
but no matter the reason the shanghai
dragons did it they went a whole season
without a single win
and 40 losses they are officially the
losingest team in
major esports history but hey there's no
relegation
so at least we get to see them try it
all over again next year
thanks for watching if you want more
great content just like this be sure to
hit the subscribe button